The joe rogan experience.
My,
my son now is at the stage where loves hauling east cock.
Just tall horse pinches a at the end cause design that he's got.
I don't know.
I,
I haven't got,
I haven't got a lot of baby Cox.
The reference it against,
I think my son has a small cock but it's,
I think it grows all right.
I think he has a nice erection but I don't,
I think he has a very good at 16 months I have erections from day one.
Wow.
Like sometimes you wake him up in the morning,
he'll take his nappy off cause he's got a shit in there and it'll be a shit
covered erection.
Oh,
that's a weird connection.
And a good name for a band
12 probably retake it.
There's probably a website for it.
Uh,
it's,
it is.
Yeah.
He gets like a little tiny woody and I always think what is going on in his head
where he is wanted or needed erection.
What was the dream that he had last night?
Oh,
I know the dreams that I'm having when I wake up with an erection.
What are the ones that are like,
is that,
you know,
that cat saying suggestive things off the Ipad,
what is probably just blood in his deck?
It's probably just blind these dick or it's longing for something that he,
you know,
I don't know.
Do you ever get boners when you driving for no apparent reason?
I have,
yes I have.
Those are weird.
Those are those who like you're still having your Dick boners sometimes you go
to have sex and you gotta fucking work at a bit to get it going and then like
other times you ever done that one where you masturbate in the car while you're
driving,
you're going to buy because you've been stuck in traffic.
And then I W I was all right with it in Britain,
but too many people in this town drive SUV.
Oh,
I drive,
I drive a car or a challenge or I'm lower down.
Oh I get seen by a lot of people got to get the windows or I could just stop
waking in my car or just get one of those things
women use when they breastfeed in public and just jerk off onto that.
Yeah,
get a quilt.
I found out the best thing to do is to plug my phone into the iPod connection
and then play porn on it.
Cause then I'll get with subwoofer and everything surround sound port in my car.
That's a good move.
So do you like hold it with one hand and steer with like the last thing?
I know,
but you have to be in traffic so I'm not doing that much steer.
And how often he beaten off in your car?
I,
since I've lived in La last five years,
I know of three times this has happened.
It's not like I'm not going to do it like right now,
like a hobby.
This is like I've,
I've just been somewhere,
there's some girls got me going.
I mean a bit of a frenzy or I've just had a fight with my girlfriend.
I'm in a bit of a bad mood.
I need to cheer myself up.
I only beat off once in my car ever.
And it was when I was driving limos.
I was driving home from a Gig.
Uh,
I had to drop some lady off in New Hampshire,
drive way the fuck up in New Hampshire.
It's a long ride back,
like an hour and a half back.
I got boards I'd beat off and I remember the fucking massive feeling of
disappointment in myself that I jerked off because I'm jerking off underneath my
shirt.
As soon as I came,
I was like,
God damn it.
This is going to be a thing I do all the time now.
And I never did it again.
I was shocked,
but it never came up.
I never wanted to do it again,
but I'm shocked because I figured I'm such a fucking idiot once I do something
embarrassing like that,
I'm like,
well this is something I do now.
This is not going to be,
I'm not going to like,
I remember once having sex with a go and she was just yelling at fuck me,
daddy fucked me.
Ooh,
right.
And I kind of went,
hey,
what are you calling me like this fort?
And then I slightly enjoy it as saying it.
I don't,
I don't need that to be a thing.
Yeah,
don't make that a thing for me because then I'm fucked up.
But I've got to ask other people to do it and then we're in a real fucking
predicament.
When I was in Boston,
I was,
I used to bang this really crazy Portuguese chick.
She used to call her pussy cunt.
It was the first girl I'd ever,
ever heard say that.
She's like fucked up,
fuck doctor.
She was like angry about it and I was like,
I hope I don't start liking this.
That's going to be hard to get someone else to agree to.
Well,
a lot of gals.
Yeah,
it's hard when you've got a thing and you've got to ask you go to do that thick.
I for a while there,
I loved choking girls while I was fucking him for awhile.
I'm not as Chokey as I used to be.
Well,
I used to be.
I used to be very fucking hand around the neck,
pinion down while I was fucking you.
Right.
And some girls and I was dating a girl had got off and doing that.
And that was,
that's what got me into it was this was how I made this.
Then you meet the goals that don't want you to do that.
But then I met one girl who I was choking her and then,
uh,
you know,
I'm not checking the whole time.
Right.
And then I've stopped and she's thought of thought,
oh,
this is what we're doing,
is it?
She starts choking me and I'm like,
don't do that.
That feels horrible.
I don't know how bad it feels for you women,
but it really hurts my mail neck.
The choking thing is,
it's weird.
It's just like one of those other things where some people love it and some
people hate it and you never fucking know until it comes up.
You know,
you could date a girl and I have no idea.
She likes to be choked.
Like the,
the first girl that I ever dated that lock to be choked was so girly.
Yeah,
she was like,
so like you would never,
she was,
it wasn't loud.
She always wore dresses.
She Wa she wasn't like boisterous or you know,
it ever slutty.
Just a regular girl and she fucking loved it.
She asked me to choke her and those,
I was like,
what do you mean choke you?
Like how,
how do you mean choke you?
She goes,
just grabbed my neck.
Why are you fucking man?
I'm like,
okay,
hard.
You want me to hurt you?
Like what's going on here?
Like,
and then if you thought about doing it to another girl,
they would freak out.
Like it's weird what?
Like one person,
what's their big turn on?
And another person,
it's a sourdough is bad when you,
when you bring the choke into it go.
He doesn't want it.
It's always bad.
Yeah.
Like Ah,
I was with a girl that I had an iron deficiency and every time she would want me
to choke her,
the next day she would just have like these horrible bruises around her neck and
she just would have to like wear like turtle necks and stuff.
But it looked like if I ever got in trouble,
I'm fucked,
Sandra.
Okay.
Yeah.